ce soir encore c'est donc au déluge qui
s'abat sur le sud de la france que nous
consacrons une grande partie de ce
journal pour commencer et pour en
prendre la mesure voyez ces images
saisissantes tourné par l'une de mes
équipes qui a pu sillonner la région en
hélicoptère de montpellier paralysé par
les trombes d'eau à avignon en passant
par les faubourgs de nîmes
nathalie jour damrémont chapelât en
panne au milieu de nulle part c'est
montpellier ce soir
des morceaux de route ce couple s'est
fait prendre au piège vraiment dès leur
entrée chez nous j'aime ma mère qui est
sûre la paillade en charge à la bande à
essayer de rentrer chez nous ce soir et
puis on est bloqué depuis depuis le
puits de leur a pris une autoroute à
l'arrêt les artères de la ville sont
bouchés son stade de la mosson
une gigantesque piscine au sol on ne
circule plus on marche on annonçait les
orages
ils ont été ponctuels des pans entiers
de la ville en témoignent les roues sous
les flots le vaucluse englouti voici
l'île de la barthelasse avalé par le
rhône près d'avignon s'est monté d'un
coup hier soir sa tenue brutalement
cette cote d' alerte le fleuve ne
l'atteint qu'une fois tous les cent ans
alors gilbert aménagements
comme la profondeur un bar en bas au
plus
ah oui forme et c'est de mettre de l'eau
partout sources dont les robinets un ton
courant non plus j'attends le groupe
augure maman portait mon beau frère
d'après la vérité voilà que les voilà
maintenant quelques mois ça comme aux
temps héroïques à la débrouille
l'habitude aussi parce que les crues du
rhône ne surprennent plus de 800
habitants de l'île elle ne les effraie
pas non plus n'y a que c'est vrai ça là
j'ai commencé ma mère à mon âge il
j'appellerai pong baby boom et a
remporté 20 pour retrouver moi tout seul
les faits si le ciel est de la partie
ceux de la barthelasse pourront sortir
de chez eux dans quelques jours le temps
de la décrue celle qui leur rendra leur
île